BUT NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY NAME
THAT TUBE. NAME THAT TUBE.
(CHEERING, WHOOPING)
IT'S EXACTLY LIKE NAME THAT
TUNE, BUT FOR WEIRD SONGS ON
YOUTUBE THAT YOU'VE ALMOST
DEFINITELY NEVER HEARD OF, AND
PERHAPS WILL NEVER HEAR AGAIN.
SO WE'RE GONNA PLAY YOU A SONG.
FOR 250 POINTS, TELL US WHAT YOU
THINK IT SHOULD BE CALLED.
ALL RIGHT? THEN WE'LL GIVE YOU
BONUS POINTS IF YOU SING THAT
SHIT.
ALL RIGHT, FIRST ONE.
THIS MAIL-ORDER BRIDE.
>> ♪ EVERYTHING I TELL YOU
MAKES YOU WANT TO LEAVE ME
THAT'S WHY YOU CAN'T STOP ASKING
♪ IF YOU'RE SO SHY
INTIMATE DETAILS... ♪
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE, WHOOPING)
>> HARDWICK: INTIMATE DETAILS.
♪ MY LITTLE BROTHER IS
MAGNETIC... ♪
(LAUGHTER)
I PLAY SPOONS ON HIM!
NICK OFFERMAN.
>> ROB SCHNEIDER'S FINAL SWING.
(LAUGHTER)
(WHOOPING)
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, I THINK IT
IS. POINTS.
DANA.
>> SHE IS THAT RARE COMBINATION
OF FRED FLINTSTONE AND WILMA
FLINTSTONE.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
YEAH, POINTS. IF THAT'S YOUR...
>> BUT THE NAME OF THE SONG
IS...
♪ I LIKED HIM BETTER AS BORAT.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
UH, YOU GET 100 POINTS FOR THAT.
HOW ABOUT THIS BANGER FROM
BANGS?
>> ♪ LET ME TAKE YOU TO THE
MOVIES, SHORTY
I'M SURE LATER ON YOU WILL BE MY
BABY. ♪
(BELL DINGS)
>> HARDWICK: WHO SEEMS TO
POSSESS THE POWER OF
TELEPORTATION.
DANA.
>> THAT'S, UH, EBONY AND
EBONIER.
>> HARDWICK: HUH.
UH.
UH...
POINTS.
>> WEREN'T THOSE...
WEREN'T THOSE GUYS KILLED ON
"THE WIRE"?
>> HARDWICK: NO.
>> TOO SOON.
>> HARDWICK: NO COMMENT.
AIMEE.
>> ♪ IT'S THE SOMALIAN PIRATE
SHUFFLE. ♪
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
POINTS TO AIMEE MANN.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
THIS ODE TO MEXICAN FOOD, I
THINK?
>> ♪ TAQUITOS
MAMA LIKE
PAPA LIKE
BURRITOS ♪
(BELL DINGS)
>> HARDWICK: YES, AIMEE MANN?
>> ♪ OH, MY GOD, LOOK HOW YOUNG
HARRY DEAN STANTON LOOKS. ♪
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
HE TOTALLY LOOKS LIKE HARRY DEAN
STANTON.
NICK.
>> WE GET MORE POINTS FOR
SINGING?
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
>> THAT'S WHY I'M TRYING TO
CATCH UP.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
>> UH, ♪ ME PENIS ES MUCHO
GUSTO. ♪
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, KEEP POINTING
AT IT.
KEEP... EVERY TIME YOU DO A
JOKE... YEAH, PERFECT.
YEAH, INDICATE, INDICATE.
LET'S JUST UNBUTTON THAT SECOND
BUTTON, NICK.
JUST LET IT HAPPEN, JUST WORK
WITH IT, LET IT HAPPEN.
200 POINTS TO NICK OFFERMAN.
DANA.
(WOMAN MOANS)
>> I DON'T...
SOMEONE DROPPED A BEN WA.
UH, I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE SONG
IS CALLED, BUT I KNEW, THOUGH,
THAT'S FROM CHISSUM
WORTHINGTON'S ALBUM "HANKY FULL
OF CHISSUM".
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
YEAH.
>> RECENTLY...
>> HARDWICK: OR...
>> RECENTLY VOTED THE MOST
CAREFULLY-PRONOUNCED ALBUM OF
THE YEAR.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, NEXT
ONE-- THIS DYSFUNCTIONAL FAMILY
BAND.
>> ♪ I HAVE A FRIEND IN JESUS
>> ♪ JESUS IS A FRIEND OF MINE
>> ♪ JESUS IS MY FRIEND
>> HARDWICK: YES, I VERY MUCH
THINK JESUS SAID TO THEM, LIKE,
"YEAH, WE SHOULD JUST BE
FRIENDS, UH...
IT'S ME, IT'S ME, IT'S NOT YOU,
IT'S ME."
(BELL DINGS)
NICK OFFERMAN.
>> UH, THIS IS THE ONLY VIDEO
THAT MORMONS ARE ALLOWED TO JERK
OFF TO.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
UH, AIMEE.
>> I'M NOT GONNA SING THIS,
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
DISRESPECTFUL.
THE SONG IS CALLED "GLORY
HOLE-LLELUJAH".
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS, IT IS.
IT IS.
I... HOW CAN IT NOT BE?
DANA.
>> I'M NOW GOING TO DO SOMETHING
REALLY STUPID AND SING IN FRONT
OF A PROFESSIONAL SINGER.
>> HARDWICK: OKAY.
>> ♪ THEY ASKED ME...
>> HARDWICK: WELL, DANA, I'M NOT
A PROFESSIONAL SINGER, LIKE...
>> WELL, TO ME, YOU ARE.
>> HARDWICK: I MEAN, I, AS A
HOBBY, I LIKE TO, YOU KNOW...
♪ SPIN TUNES OCCASIONALLY.
I MEAN, I DON'T WANT TO... GET
INTO IT NOW.
IT'S ALL RIGHT.
>> I STILL HAVE YOUR EIGHT-TRACK
"AFTERNOON MOVES".
♪ THEY ASKED ME IF I LIKED IT,
AND I SAID "I DON'T KNOW,
IT LOOKS LIKE LUKE SKYWALKER
DRESSED UP LIKE HAN SOLO." ♪
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS,
PERFECT, I LIKE IT.
LAST ONE-- THIS MOST TALENTED
KARDASHIAN.
>> ♪ LA, LA, LA, LA, LA
LA, LA, LA, LA, LA,
LA, LA, LA. ♪
(BELL DINGS)
>> HARDWICK: I'M GONNA SAY
THAT'S KIM KARDASHIAN'S
PERPETUAL INNER MONOLOGUE.
THAT'S... LIKE, WHEN YOU SEE HER
ON THE COVER OF THE MAGAZINE
WITH HER ASS STICKING OUT,
THAT'S WHAT'S PLAYING IN HER
HEAD ON A LOOP.
UH, NICK OFFERMAN.
>> UH, WE HAVE CHECHNYAN GUN
MONEY-- LET US MAKE VIDEO.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS TO NICK.
DANA.
>> UH, WELL, I'M... FEEL LIKE I
SHOULD ALMOST RECUSE MYSELF,
BECAUSE I'M A BIG GNESA "WILDER"
FAN.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
>> AND, UM, THIS IS ACTUALLY
FROM HER ALBUM "MY BUSH LOOKS
LIKE LENNY KRAVITZ IS TYING MY
SHOES".
>> HARDWICK: PO...
POINTS.
>> PEOPLE... PEOPLE CALL ME
"DAD."
>> HARDWICK: NOT... NOT JUST
YOUR KIDS.